So thinking about the exercise for a second, what does adequacy mean?
Well, there's no abstract invariant.
And that really means you don't have to worry about anything for
this particular property, for this exercise.
Or you can think about the in,
the abstract invariant as just being the Boolean, value, true.
If we make this simplification then the above adequacy criterion looks
like the following.
For every abstract state S, there's going to be a concrete state T.
And in that state the concrete invariance hold and
if we apply the retrieve function to that state we get back to S.
What this means is that we have to check for each situation we can get into,
with the abstract specification there corresponds a valid concrete one.